tassé du charolais donc c'est quand même
assez costaud et puis ça c'est un boeuf
médiévale les archéologues sur les
chantiers tombe souvent sur des eaux
par milliers les poubelles n'existait
pas aux temps anciens l'archéozoologue
laiterie un parent et met tous ses sens
à contribution on goûte et quand c'est
de l'os c'est au niveau de la langue ça
donne un aspect ça accroche cette
séquence et de lapierre conseil général
de manière générale c'est froid à
travers les animaux mangent et la
scientifique reconstitue la faune d'une
époque on a très peu de serre on a
surtout du lièvre et ça c'est plutôt
synonyme d' espaces ouverts aux papas
fortement boisée en tout cas à la maison
de l'archéologie les spécialistes des
aux animaux et humains côtoient les
restauratrices elles ne sont pas
archéologues mais spécialiste du
traitement des matières
leur but qu'aucune information ne se
perde cette clé gallo romaine a été
passé aux rayons x pour aider la
restauratrice a retrouvé la surface
d'origine
quant aux objets et brut de fouilles en
fait il est complètement corrodé
recouverte de sédiments et on n'a pas
accès à l'information en fait la
première approche est pas intuitive on
voit l'objet on ne sait pas forcément ce
qu'il était et donc il ya vraiment une
notion de redécouverte et il ya un
aspect magique et forcément la magie
lié aussi à l'émotion de cette
découverte
les restauratrices remonte le temps et
les objets pour les exposer dans les
musées l'idée c'est vraiment pas de
refabriquer une clé mais c'est de
chercher à révoquer et à montrer aux
gens ce qu'étaient ces objets à l'époque
où les les gallo romains ou les
enfin les gens les utiliser ce vase et
reconstruit pas forcément au complet ce
sera le travail de l'archéologue
d'interpréter son profil un profil
archéologiques c'est avoir le profil du
col ou au pied sans pour autant qu'elle
soit qu'elles soient en tire donc celle
ci à la com ça pouvoir l'a dessinée
prendre l'empreinte et puis là la
reporter
la descente quelque sorte nous verrons
demain comment les céramologue grâce aux
vaisselle cassée retrace le quotidien
des gens pauvres ou riches